هذا وكانت شبه جزيره القرم قد شهدت هجمات
عده هذا العام من ابرزها في الثمن من
اكتوبر العام الماضي قالت السلطات الروسيه
ان تفجيرا وقعه في شاحنه مفخخه على جسر
الذي يربط شبه جزيره القرم باراضي الدوله
وادى الى دمار وانهيار جزئي في مساري عبور
السيارات واوقف حركه النقل عرضه القوات
الروسيه في العشرين من اغسطس لهجوم ايضا
بطائره مسيره استهدفت الاسطول الروسي في
البحر الاسود في مدينه سيفا ستوبل
واسقطتها الدفاعات الجويه الروسيه اما في
السادس عشر من الشهر نفسه فعلت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه وقوع اصابات نتيجه
مواصفاتها بعمليه تخريبيه في مستودع ذخيره
بالقرب من بلده مايسكوي الشماليه شبه
جزيره القرم قبل ايام اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه انفجارا لذخائر جويه وقع في منطقه
مطار س اكيا العسكري وتسبب في انفجارات
قرب بلده نوفو فيدوفكا اما في العشرين
مليون يورو حزيران فقد اتهمت السلطات
المحليه المواليه لروسيا اوكرانيا
باستهداف ثلاثه منصات في بحريات تابعه
لشركه في البحر الاسود تبعد نحو 150
كيلومترا عن شبه جزيره صقر